mon grand-père en fait ça a été un peu
mon premier fan il a 90 ans aujourd'hui
et il me suit vraiment sur plein de
dates de tournée il a déjà vu le
spectacle 2000 fois et
il rit quand même toujours à chaque fois
[Musique]
nous sommes allés la voir quand même le
plus régulièrement possible vous êtes
vraiment de ceux qui sont venus le plus
souvent dès le début des frais de la
voiture et viennent quatre coins de la
France
en Belgique malgré tout le spectacle les
deux spectacles le spectacle qui se
suivent ne seront jamais papier collés
il y a toujours des nuances des
différences des réactions
alors papa a pour habitude de garder
absolument tout tout ce qui me concerne
donc je pense que vraiment le moindre
article où on parle de moi le moindre
phrase où on parle de moi dans un
article c'est sûr c'est sûr il a et il
était là dès le début quand j'ai
commencé à monter sur scène les
premières fois
la particulière parce qu'il y a mon
grand-père qui est dans la salle
et ça c'est vrai je crois qu'il est
là-bas qui est là-bas
il est décédé
sachant qu'il était dans la salle je
décide l'après-midi sur un coup de tête
de d'écrire une chanson pour mon
grand-père
et je décide vraiment ça enfin deux
heures avant le spectacle et donc à la
fin du spectacle je sors mon truc ou le
pupitre je mets le texte comme ça je
sais que j'ai le texte et en fait ce que
j'avais pas pensé c'est que c'était
possible d'oublier l'air de la chanson
et donc j'avais le texte mais je ne
savais plus du tout l'air que j'avais
composé
de tous les gens ma famille qui m'ont vu
sur scène c'est
[Musique]
les gens je pense ne comprenez pas bien
ce qui se passait et je pense qu'il
pensait que je faisais semblant de ne
pas me souvenir donc il pensait que je
faisais des vannes et du coup j'avais
mon téléphone à côté de moi je m'étais
enregistré l'après-midi en train de la
chanter et donc j'ai pris mon téléphone
et j'essayais d'écouter l'air pour me
rappeler comment aller la chanson
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais du coup dans l'album j'ai eu envie
de refaire cette chanson de
l'enregistrer correctement avec le
bonheur avec les bonnes paroles bon là
si il y a pas encore la couverture et
tout c'est parce que c'est pas bon
première mais en tout cas c'est le
premier
merci merci quelle surprise qu'elle
surprise
[Musique]
de tous les gens de ma famille qui m'ont
vu sur scène c'est le seul qui a pas
changé de nom
sur moi il aime tellement lire des
articles que je suis sûr que c'est lui
qui lance toutes les polémiques mais
quand il ne lit pas il ne perd pas son
temps il se tape même une petite jeune
de 75 ans
[Musique]
on n'est pas de la même famille pour
rien
[Musique]
innovation pour papa
oui oui effectivement
c'est beaucoup mieux que la première
[Rires]
[Musique]